you guys there's a lot to talk about
first of all what a night to be in the
ballroom Hannah your face when they
announce James was being sent home
what's going through you guys is mine
because you and James were these two
frontrunners from the start I feel like
James has just been amazing the whole
time he's not just amazing on the dance
where he's an amazing human and he's
been he was when we met and Good Morning
America he came up to me and just I
didn't know him yet he just like can I
give you a hug because I feel like you
need a hug
he's like I watched your season for the
first time and it was just I don't know
I just
from then on I just thought of him as
like a father figure and this whole
thing and he would always just
encouraging when I would be my crazy
self and so to see him go it was really
upsetting because he's been a big part
of my journey as well and it was but it
was nice to be able to know that I now
have a relationship with him to be able
to give him that hug that he gave me and
so I'm gonna miss him a lot we we spent
every day together and which we did show
ends healthy and we were permanent homes
we just yeah it's there James and I love
James that ever have such a good energy
that they literally whenever he ever get
into a little problem they're like oh
you guys are father figure to me that's
what I was kind of wondering is if you
pictured you two in it together at the
end and this has to be shocking I feel
like we had our own team name I thought
like us for because yeah Allen Allen
Bama yeah because we just really
connected with each other and
each other through the whole thing so
yeah I did I thought I thought for sure
he was the front-runner three he'd never
been in the bottom two yeah
by the way though I got to tell you you
are now in the finals and you've never
been in the bottom we can't even be in
the bottom two that's guys that's
honestly because of oh my gosh guys
seriously I have the best fans and I'm
like I need to look in the camera
because I anything that I've done I have
had so much support so much love and I
feel it and I see it and it's just been
so incredible that I know I can count on
my fans and we've been through a lot
together so this is a big celebration
not just for me not just for Allen not
just for us as a team but for everybody
I mean we saw some of that tonight too
there were tears there was so much you
you came to cariann and you said I want
to kind of clarify this why was that
important for you it was it seeing the
package and then making sure you wanted
to be understood properly yeah
absolutely I think you only see two
minutes and I'm very aware of this like
when things get your life kind of gets
cut down and I was very emotional that
day it was the first time we had done
our contemporary contemporary knew the
story behind it started allowing those
emotions to come into practice in like a
real way and it was hard to have cameras
and to even take any criticism at that
point and I want to get better and I
want to improve and it's not the
criticism that like upset me it was more
just the day and I think it's okay
because I'm human
she just unfortunately had to come in at
the wrong time didn't have to do that
and so I just wanted her to know and
that her critiques her help is really
important for me to get better and
better and I
appreciate that it's just okay you said
a weight had been lifted off you when
you did that dance tonight so does it
feel like finally those those X's are
fully behind you the weight is off yeah
I feel like when you kind of put
yourself out the way I did so it's
really Bo and it gets brought up all the
time and you know you want to move
forward we want to get past it and I
feel like that dance was a way for me to
from in my heart and myself to be like
this is gone and now it's me and I think
moving forward you know I'm always going
to be asked about my experience and the
men that were there but it's like this
was a way for me not just for myself but
for the rest of America that's watching
my journey to know that like I'm good
and I am okay because all that needs to
be put behind so that I could become an
empowered woman that gets to me my story
so yeah you know what I did kind of love
Peters first promo came out did you see
it the windmills in it like I said I
will always be asked to go yeah it's
just I guess I'm I don't know that was a
memorable moment I think for everyone so
I do have to ask you look he's we know
he's rapping filming up now what advice
would you give him as things wind down
what advice would you pass on what
questions should he be asking those
final women god that's really hard for
me to give I think it's just taking
those moment
to really get to know the person without
the cameras and to make sure that you're
really vulnerable and honest with each
other just because it's the show is in
your ended your life is still start
starting and to really get to know like
what you're you're in and be able to
make confident decisions for yourself
moving forward too just because the show
ends doesn't mean that's the ending you
really need to understand what your
relationship is and I hope that his is a
fairy tale and something that he's
always been looking for last question
for you guys how will you attack the
finals Allen I think you were shirtless
all night will you be shirtless next
week just shake it up I might put a
shirt on who knows might rip it off yeah
I'm really excited for the free styles
it's gonna be amazing
it's like a continuation of a
celebration of me yeah it's gonna be a
huge celebration to make the finals is
honestly a winner so I just want to
enjoy this weekend make it as memorable
as possible you may be the only person
to ever not be in the final two and make
the finals it's the worst
[Music]
[Music]